yo what's up it's your roomie and in
this video I'm gonna talk to you about
how I built a chat button hours this is
over the weekend launched it and
generated thousands of messages via this
chat if you're sending building your own
chat bot this video is for you let me
talk to you a little bit more about why
I built this chat pod
I've been someone that has been reading
a lot about chat bots in Lille even on
chat bots magazine I've seen bought last
set he's the founder of buffalos he's
incredible I've seen all this posts on
you know I follow him on Facebook and on
Twitter and everywhere and I see all
these chat BOTS that have been launched
on product time it was definitely
something now I needed to learn more
about and for me the easiest way to
learn something is by immersing myself
in that in by building a side project in
doing and my goal was you not only learn
about Chaffetz but learn about the chat
bot ecosystem and the tools that were
out there I found myself looking on an
actual on a browser window and I was
looking at some artwork from an artist
that I like Alec monopoly so you might
have seen some of this work it's kind of
like a monopoly man her feeding street
art but I'm pretty much obsessed a lot
of his work and some other artworks I
was like why don't I build a chat bot
for people to discover artist artwork
and purchase all through messenger so I
kind of come up with my initial idea and
just out of like the fact that I like
artwork and that would be a cool way to
get involved and combine my interest
through this project of a chat bot first
off is like alright like let's just
start to Google and you know and look on
product ton see if there's any kind of
art chat bot that's out there well as I
just said our chat bot that's exactly
how I came upon the name so I
immediately went to GoDaddy and I typed
in dubby dubby dubby not our chat calm
in to my surprise man it was available
so I click purchase on at
99 I had the domain name just like my
studio time I used Squarespace logo
generator which is like a visual kind of
logo creation tool so I didn't have to
photoshop I didn't have to sketch or any
sophisticated designing tool I simply
use Squarespace logo generator to
generate the initial little bit for our
chat bot so I had the name domain and
logo now I needed to figure out how am I
actually gonna build this so I started
researching some tools and then also
joining some the chat bot developer
groups on Facebook which I can link down
here to some of those rich a huge
resource and a lot of you know knowledge
sharing going on but I found chat tool
so chapter tool is an easy way to create
a chat bot and it's it basically a
visual open a chat pod creation platform
and I started to just see what the other
options were and I just said okay I'm
just gonna commit to using chap you'll
learn how to use it so it's not for chat
fuel super easy platform used by the way
they actually have templates that that
are on there so you can get started
using a template and modify it towards
your knees now once I pretty my account
through brute jet fuel in the Facebook
page for our chat bot which I needed
because that's all people who are going
to send a message to our chat bot I just
got started using one of their
placeholder templates and I just
understood from their chat BOTS are all
about conversation design so just like
when you wrote when you roadmap an app
or even a website kind of wire framing
process you can use that similar process
to actually create the chat bot using
chap tool so you can think about things
like blocks and so when someone types an
initial
you know this block then goes to a next
block and you can have different
variable blocks to send them different
messages or display other information
and then all of that together composes
this kind of conversational design of
the chat box it's really not that
complicated you know to be honest it's
probably one of the easiest things I've
ever built and that's our chat box so
within about 30 minutes I have the
initial template in place for our chat
bot and I just started testing real-time
the messaging on this and you started
iterating the conversational design of
what our travel would be and what it
actually is now in the stages it is live
and I'll link down here and screenshot
also the website that I created in you
can actually test it out yourself and
let me know what you think and give me
some feedback on it I'll you know
obviously want to improve it but you can
kind of get a really good idea of that
conversation design of our chat bot so
in about 30 minutes to an hour I have
this initial version of the art chat pod
actually built what I did from there was
I wanted to go ahead and get people to
start using this what I did was I
actually open-source most of the build
and doing that I started to tweet about
what I was doing I loved people first
off no hang on building a side project
or a chat bot on Twitter I started to
join in post in a lot of these groups
for you know chat bot developers and
chat bot communities on Facebook I also
shared on my personal Facebook I also
shared on my Instagram which I'll link
down here and it's at yo roomie and then
also Instagram stories and I really show
people what I was doing
as always doing
people were becoming aware of this
chatbot project that I was building they
were giving me feedback being involved
in the process and obviously once I have
this ready to launch some people already
knew of what I was doing in it they were
aware of it and they had kind of
participated in it in some sense in
their mind so I had some leadership
first users and an initial traction
before I'd even watch keep in mind this
is literally within about the first hour
to you know two hours as I was going
through this process and letting people
know what I was doing ensuring more on
the project I also created a Google Doc
where I was going to create a public
product roadmap so people could
contribute their feedback and their
potential feature requests to this chat
pod all via link and I created a bitly
short link to that so I can send that
off you know on all my social and I
could track that but I wanted people to
be involved in this project because if
they were then they were going to have
some invest in the project and be more
willing to probably share it and I can
build some initial kind of attraction
and momentum as I launched so people at
this time were aware of what I was doing
they were giving me some feedback I was
kind of taking that feedback I was
adding it to the Google Doc and at the
same time I was being very open and
honest about how many users you can say
the chat pod had and then the amount of
messages that it was sending so I was
sharing the analytics and that is
actually something that is interesting
to a lot of people that I found out is
people want to know you know not only in
the process of how you build these
things but also like how do you actually
launch these and how effective are the
launches are people messaging it if so
what are the actual analytics likes and
these these are things that
typically startups don't share as much
so I was being open and honest in open
sourcing mostess which was actually at
some kind of angle of interest that
people started becoming interested in so
at that time I had initial tripod built
and I had an initial kinetic immunity
around this that I had created the first
users one of the biggest objectives for
having a chatbot website is not only to
let people know about what the chat pod
is the functionality but simply to get
people to message it because once you
send a message to a chat pod that is
technically considered a user and on
sees air quotes because that's you know
loosely defined but that is an opt-in as
considered a user and for analytics that
starts the messages that are account as
messages and actually sit down I'll link
to it down here and I'll screenshot with
you the current website but it is wwr
chafa calm but as you can see i just
simply have the name the logo the
tagline I have a large button that's a
call to action then I have a visual
image of the art chat bot and some of
the artwork that's displayed and then
also at the very bottom in the footer I
do have a link to that open source of
Google Doc so people that come to the
site can not only see our chat bot not
only send a message but be aware of hey
you can contribute your feedback to our
chat bot and you can see the analytics
real-time kind of open source of this
project and stay up to date and in the
loop with this I've actually found that
there's been thousands of hits to that
Google Doc and a lot of people are very
interested in how many messages are
being sent to and contributing to this
it's just been a really cool project for
me and not only have I learned a lot
about chat bots you know built out a
network
other chatbot developers of people that
are working on you know building chat
box and tools to the developer ecosystem
but also to perfecting my process of not
only how do I approach side projects but
how do I build them how do i market them
how do I share more information about
these projects to people and then also
learning what are people interested in
you know seeing with these side projects
and really sharing it so that's one of
the biggest things that I like doing is
just being open and honest and open
sourcing a lot of these side projects
and sharing my people hopefully you know
a little bit more about art chatbot how
I'm approaching chatbots and how I got
started building this how effective it's
been I'll link down below to all the
tools and resources that I use to build
this chap off and hit subscribe it's
that way I can keep making these videos
and comment below to let me know any
questions that you have on chat BOTS or
anything relevant to this and also what
you want me to make my next video on see
ya
[Music]
you